نحن هنا في ساحه الطرف الاغر وسط العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن نرقب وصول الملك تشارلز
الثالث الى هذه الساحه التي اغلقت في
ساعات ظهيره هذا اليوم وصل ليقدم التعازي
في ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا في هذه
الخيمه التي نصبت هنا في وسط ساحه الطرف
الاغر المغلق الان امام الجمهور خيمه نصبت
لمجموعه من الهيئات والمنظمات والجمعيات
السوريه السياسيه والاغاثيه التي ستستقبل
التعازي بضحايا الزلزال خلال الايام
القليله المقبله حتى يوم الجمعه المقبل
الملك تشارلز الثالث جاء من منطقه هونزلو
غربيه لندن حيث التقى
بمتطوعين يجمعون التبرعات والمساعدات
لضحايا الزلزال من الجاليه التركيه تحديدا
وقال لنا منظموا هذه الخيمه ان المكتب
مكتب قصر
تواصل مع هذه المنظمات السوريه وطلبوا
منهم عنوانا يتوجه اليه الملك لتقديم
التعازي للضحيه السوريين بهذا الزلزال
ويطلع على بعض التفاصيل كما ذكر لي
المنظمون بعض التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالنجيم من الزلزال بعض الاقارب الذين
يعيشون هنا في المملكه المتحده اقارب
ضحايا الزلزال سيطلعون الملك على قصصهم
سيروون له حكاياتهم
وسيتحدثون عن ما تحتاجه سوريا في هذه
الفتره العصيبه بعد ان الحق الزلزال الضرر
والدمار واوضح بحياه الالاف محمد المدهون
الجزيره لندن